let's hear from people in the audience
on this slightly early friday type show
because the week is a little bit
different this week we take calls via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord and we're going to start today
with alex from california alex welcome
what's on your mind today
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
nice so
when it comes to like elections and how
people vote it really seems like it
comes down to
the economy than anything else like
um you could have things like roe v wade
or like gay marriage be overturned but
if there's like a recession in that same
year it feels like they'll vote on the
like recession and say oh democrats
uh ruin the economy who cares about um
these like um civil rights issues yeah
what do you think about that i
completely agree
the perception of how the economy is
doing even if number one people's
perception is wrong
and number two it doesn't really have
much to do with the president
um both
are
um
hugely influential in how people vote
and this is why things are suddenly
looking much better for democrats even
though i don't think it really has much
to do with joe biden there was this
blockbuster jobs report in july wages
are up inflation's down gas prices are
down etc it has very little to do with
joe biden
but it seems to be helping democrats
very much in terms of the outlook for
november so yes it's the economy stupid
was the phrase james carville came up
with and it uh it is more like it is the
perception of the economy regardless of
whether it's accurate
okay so let's say um i've been here a
lot of like recession warnings coming up
they say there's going to be like a
recession in like 2024 let's say there
is
so
is is that going to be the determining
factor whether or not like joe biden
loses the election even though like
democrat uh the republican agenda is
like has really awful things like
to like to do or or want to do sorry
i don't know you're saying if there is a
recession or you're saying there won't
be one yeah no i'm saying if there is a
recession that's pretty much a
guaranteed loss for like joe biden if he
if he decides to run yeah i think if at
the time if i think if joe biden runs
for reelection and there is a very clear
recession in september and october of
2024 i think biden definitely loses
that's so far off and remember people
have been predicting imminent recessions
since 2015
and it hasn't really happened i mean you
could argue technically we just were in
one because gdp went down very very
slightly last quarter but when you look
at every other indicator it's really
hard to make that case but let's wait
and see i agree with you though if there
is really a recession it's going to be
bad for joe biden if he's on the on the
ticket
all right that's it devin thank you for
taking my call thank you appreciate it
uh very very good questions
who doesn't love a good cereal the
crunchiness the sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood
with zero grams of sugar only four to
five net carbs perfect if you're doing
keto only 140 calories per serving and
packed with 14 to 15 grams of protein
magic spoon spent years developing the
recipes it's really the only cereal on
the market to get the texture and the
flavor right without the sugar and
without a ton of carbs they have flavors
like cocoa honey nut fruity peanut
butter maybe you want to go adventurous
they've got blueberry muffin maple
waffle cookies and cream or cinnamon
roll that brings back memories i love
magic spoon the whole team does but if
you don't you'll get a full refund but i
know it's about to become your new
favorite cereal you'll get five dollars
off when you go to magicspoon.com
pacman the link is down below